when it comes to the priorities for
setting up a diet for recomping what you
want to make sure is first of all
looking at total energy intake it's got
to be low enough
to be compatible with a modest rate of
fat loss but
caloric intake cannot be so low as to
dramatically blunt hypertrophy and there
was a recent meta-analysis by murphy and
colleagues where they looked at how a
certain magnitude of energy deficit
impacts hypertrophy potential and what
they found was that as the energy
deficit grew by a hundred calories a day
the effect size for gains and lean mass
did drop
by about
0.03 units now that's practically
not very easy to kind of digest but i
think that the key takeaway there is
as the deficit got bigger
lean mass gains became more challenging
and as the deficit got up to about 500
calories per day that was where the
regression line predicted a full uh
essentially a full attenuation of gains
in lean mass now i'm not saying that
that is a
generalizable theoretical truth and that
no one can gain lean mass in a 500
calorie per day deficit but that's where
the data indicated as you're getting up
near 500 calories a day for your deficit
it's going to be pretty tough sledding
so i think that's helpful in kind of
dictating the
ideal deficit to shoot for and as an
extension of that kind of what kind of
rate of weight loss you can potentially
be aiming for
you know as you extend that information
out
the other thing you want to focus on so
calorie intake has to be low enough to
support some fat loss but high enough to
support uh gains in lean mass you also
need to make sure that your protein is
high enough to support gaining muscle so
in most cases based on the evidence i'm
seeing 1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram of
body mass
still seems to be a good range there
nothing wrong with going higher but
there are obviously trade-offs as
protein gets higher it starts displacing
other macronutrients it starts limiting
food choices to some extent it can make
you so full that it's kind of
challenging to maintain a diet in some
cases so 1.6 to 2.2 should be fine in
many cases but
since that's scaled to total body mass
it can really fall apart when you get to
extreme ends of body composition ranges
just based on normative data
so uh you know because that ultimately
that range was calculated based on the
typical body comp of the typical study
participant uh so pretty much a large
portion of it is college-aged folks and
say hey you want to come do a study and
make 75 bucks like that's pretty much
where that that number's coming from
yeah so if you're
really really lean um you know
or or you're on the higher end of the
body fat spectrum those numbers might
not work out as well in that case i'd
say probably somewhere between 2 and
2.75 grams per kilogram of fat free mass
just making your best estimate that
should put you in a pretty similar range
you can make an evidence-based argument
that there are some circumstances
where in order for recomping to be
feasible you should bump that up to 2.3
to 3.1 grams per kilogram of fat-free
mass
but from the data i've seen the only
situation where that really applies is
if you're quite lean or dieting very
hard and you're just trying to hang on
to some hope of retaining or potentially
gaining fat free mass in the process but
that scenario alone is automatically a
bit of a long shot for recomposition so
my recomposition guideline like i said
1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram of total
mass or 2 to 2.75 grams per kilogram of
fat free mass if you're in a
physiological state where recomping is
feasible
those guidelines should make it happen
if you're in a state where body body
recomposition is not feasible for you
then then it ain't gonna work uh and so
that's the reality of the situation but
i think
uh getting back to the perception of the
feasibility of recomping i think it is a
goal that is accessible to more people
than the average lifter might think